la familia de alexander doguín aseguró
que el atentado iba dirigido a él pues
era él quien se iba a desplazar en el
coche donde pusieron la bomba que
representa doguín en rúsia
bien efectivamente se supone que el
objeto de este atentado hubiera sido el
pues tiene un perfil mucho más alto que
su propia hija que era politólogo y
analista
pero el digamos lidera este movimiento
euroasiático hace mucho tiempo una la
idea de la integración de todo el mundo
de habla rusa no de cultura rusa
pero en sí como personas no es tan
conocido dentro de rusia no es por ahí
una figura pública que cualquier
hablando con cualquier persona puede
saber de él sino que digamos tiene
influencia en algunos círculos de
pensamiento si tiene por ahí más
presencia en el exterior o es más
conocido en el exterior a partir de que
se lo presenta como el filósofo asesor
de putin aún más cercano a putin y demás
si bien ellos digamos hace tiempo que no
tienen una relación cercana y
básicamente edwin a partir de el inicio
de la crisis
ucraniana ya en 2014
promovía una acción más rápida una
guerra inmediata contra oakland y además
y en eso no no tenía la mirada pues la
misma posición y desde entonces hubo un
distanciamiento cada vez más grande no
y sin embargo en ese momento es cuando
comienza a conocerse en el exterior a
putin y coca de perdón y comienza a
crecer su influencia en el exterior
bueno y todo esto ocurre en medio de la
guerra en ucrania quiere está en el
punto de mira realmente el gobierno de
volodymyr selenski o funcionarios
ucranianos tienen la capacidad de
infiltrarse en moscú
bueno el fsb ha detectado varias células
de supuestas la gente está supuestamente
por cooperar con el gobierno aquí para
realizar atentados
ya han detenido a unos cuantos así que
la capacidad operacional es posible no y
digamos que es una metodología que se ha
utilizado antes hubo varios atentados
específicamente con coches bombas en
donges y en lugares
para recordar la muerte del líder de la
red burgués que es a heart 5 en 2018 no
digamos con ese también esa misma
metodología
es la hipótesis más grande digamos no es
la única pero en este momento la
hipótesis favorita sería la
responsabilidad del gobierno al quien
hay que ver la investigación hacia asia
donde continuo bueno divina y sus padres
fueron sancionados por eeuu desde 2014
cuando rusia se anexó la península de
crimea se puede hablar de un papel de
eeuu en este hecho
por lo que te decía anteriormente
digamos es una figura más conocida en el
exterior que dentro de rusia por lo
tanto si hay algún interés en detenerlo
en eliminar a la figura de duda pasa por
intereses que vienen desde occidente y
no tanto dentro de la misma rusia o
dentro de del mundo de habla rusa
digamos pasaría por ese lado por lo
tanto se podría inter digamos este
suponer algún tipo de influencia externa
a partir de eeuu o europa digamos pero
todavía no hay elementos para afirmarlo
directamente